[Music]
so we've been pushing our boundaries
right with the shoulder and then the Joe
work
okay um and we have a lot of there's a
lot of holes in what we're learning
right wouldn't you say Okay okay so it's
good to go back
it's it's one reason why I like that
patreon Community because we get to
retouch some of the things that maybe we
slightly altered slightly changed as we
have to reintroduce it to someone who's
just starting out okay so
um a thing to first start out there's
some common misunderstandings like
one people think you can stand in any
old way and your foot can do any old
thing and it's just not true
okay your
foot can't be
out or in this can't do any of that
stuff okay
ever your foot has to be in
alignment with your knee and the qua on
that side so this this is always
incorrect this is always wrong while I
might have knee and foot I don't have
quaw the quaw is not there okay so we
don't that's we don't do this kind of
stuff
okay
um and where we put our weight
especially on the grounding foot is at
the midfoot and we use one midfoot at a
time in techniques you never use two
midfoot you you you know ever do this
okay so where's the
midfoot uh the
midfoot is a
spot here down okay that that is where
it is so I put all my all my weight on
that if I was to be on the front midfoot
I put my
weight there so right now if you look at
my my
knee and I bring my knee to where the
Joe
is my weight is actually not underneath
that midfoot right now it is South
towards the heel to put my weight on the
midfoot all my weight my knee has to go
to the Y face which is my knee is on the
same vertical plane as my toes so if I
was doing this on the back
foot if I stand
here I'm actually not weighted on
midfoot so and that's how we stand like
that a lot in
iido you stand this is how you you stand
you see it's so comfortable you have the
skeletal alignment is what's keeping
out okay to get to midfoot I have to
take and put all my weight on midfoot as
in the C you drills I have to drop my
knee to the Y face which is knee to toes
do you guys see that okay so if
you's here and I'm doing drill one and I
stay here like that you can see how high
I am for me if you pay attention
and eventually his weight will go over
it and I I'm going to try to hold him
still see what see what F happens okay
so here I have midfoot my knee is
there all right do it slowly because I'm
going to really try I want to see what I
feel okay I I can already feel that my
my heel is being weighted you see that
so I felt that it's the first sign
so Rio I think your heel waiting is is
there you should have seen that okay so
go a little slower and let me see what I
feel past the the heel waiting there's
the heel
waiting okay and same right there and
I'm starting to
rotate I started to
rotate okay a little more I'm going to
try to not
rotate okay I feel a bite it's biting
back here as I'm trying to hold the
rotation a little
more my front foot is totally being
lifted off as my weight is Shifting past
my
heel whoa it's way on the go keep going
it's way on the heel it's way on the
heel I'm I'm way back here on the heel
you can see my toes coming off you see
and then the tension comes in the
shoulders I try to hold it and I can't
hold it it exhausted right okay
whereas first drop your weight all your
weight on the midfoot and that means
you're going to have your knee at the
toe line not not here here so let's just
look at my some differences watch my
height here's the here's the Joe you'll
reference its distance from the M here I
am on that other line here I go to y
up you see it coming up down and this is
a lot of you when I say you're not in
the M that's what's happening you're not
in the mat
drop and you're in the M okay and then
then you're here then he he just pushes
down he's making me heavier what I feel
is that my my uh I don't know Sean you
want to try it put your finger under my
midfoot or your whatever
I'll put it on
there okay so here I
[Music]
am need to midfoot line do you feel the
weight whatever that is then I start
dropping
it you feel that okay and now watch when
he when he's gradually increases it keep
going he you see it just gets heavier
and heavier and heavier okay
so uh you you have to do this because
you you do you do
this okay in Rio you do this too you
have to
get
down into the Y toe the Y knee
position okay and that means you're
probably much lower than you think
you would feel normal to to cuz
obviously you're not trying to do this
you're trying to be low and grounded but
there's no way cuz you're too high so
think exaggerate getting low okay all
right we I'll try
that
um so let's look
at here and I'm going to go to the Yang
line on the knee with the knee okay um
so there I there I am you you can give
some energ so you feel I want you to
feel it okay so there I am all right now
watch what I'm going to do with my
pelvis just keep keep it constant right
now you see I'm pointing it down and I'm
getting this you and now I'm on the arch
of my foot do you get that okay
so to put the if I follow the rule that
the knee goes to the Y lung
and that should be on my
midfoot I have to get rid of
that you see you start doing this stuff
you're going to come back to the arch
and already at his pressure that he's
doing now my shoulder is starting to
burn as I'm trying to hold this kind of
thing and you could gradually push you
you already have me there's the heel
weight and then there I go okay
so if if you follow the
rules knee to
toes mid foot it will
fix that okay but if you're in iido
culture you're going to go knee to
midfoot and you're going to create
that that
samurai samurai stance which is not
really in the samurai stance or nor in
the martial arts okay so you have to
watch that back it would be no
different if I was
here and you see this a lot in in Ikea
you see and you're going like this this
is all back bracing angle with the lower
back
instead I'm
flat here not here
here he's driving and is just
pushing that down don't go up cuz then
you'll come over
okay so another way of thinking of
it is
that everything hangs off my
spine but my spine is being hooked up
like a butcher
side of a cow it's hooked up on the
ceiling and if you curl this that would
be
weird it should just
hang and that's not going to be there
you don't want that tension in there so
by these two
metrics midfoot knee to toes you can't
do this and by the other metric my spine
just hangs from the ceiling you can't do
this either
okay so careful though cuz when I say
this especially you you come too far
under you see and now you're on your
toes not on the midfoot okay and you'll
get rolled out over the toes so same
thing boom straight I go under and
eventually keep going there I go roll
out over the side of my foot okay all
right so you your pelvis has to be in a
certain place okay and use those metrics
I gave you all right TR okay the next uh
iido
fallacy is you're up straight you're up
straight like this you
see okay
so I'll find I'll go to the Yong on off
you can give me some pressure I find the
midfoot now I'm going to do that other
stance so keep your pressure going and I
do the other stance and now I'm not
midfoot okay I get I get heel weighted
again and I eventually the force goes
over the
heel
so that's going to be I want you guys to
try that get get to the midfoot get to
the good midfoot with a good pelvis
they'll keep the pressure and then stand
up straight and you'll see Ah that's
okay all right so that's not what we do
you just follow the rules knee to toes
weight on the mid fooot pelvis in the
right place and that's the angle that
your torso is in that's the angle and
it's kind of like not here just a little
just a little forward okay here straight
and there I go okay all right try it
again all right so those adjustments and
Rio you need to make those adjustments
Margaret you're doing pretty good on all
that so coach coach Rio on those things
the next thing for both of you and for
you here okay we
think
release is relaxed it's not it's not
okay it's not relaxed uh release is a
metaphysical uh aspect of training it's
as much mind as it is the body as it is
the emotions okay it's not relaxed
you're you're not going to like uh all
those Japanese Shihan who are like super
relaxed and they they you know they do
stuff like
that okay what they're they're ukis
choreographs so who gives a that
right and hence eventually they're doing
no touch throws and things like that
it's not
not that there is no uh flexion there is
flexion and more than it's it's the
right flexion and it's not where you
wanted to be initially but more than
that there's a pressurization that
happens that is very far from this
flaccid um thing okay so um we'll do
you're going to do it okay and you're
going to push and I start to do this
come on give me some energy and
eventually I pressurize you can come
over here don't don't let up the energy
give the energy get the energy and
you're just you're just going
to uh P punch me
hard harder
harder you can push
shoulders I'm not loose
kicks to the midsection round kicks from
here it's very
pressurized harder oh
harder okay that that's not loose don't
don't do it cuz you'll kill me okay I'm
not
here and then go ahead and do like a no
no no do punch instead like okay oh no
no no it's not like that that's wrong
okay so you guys both you Rio and
Margaret you're like you're still in the
if I
relax it's it's going to magically work
it's not going to magically work okay we
have a lot of that here I'm going to
relax no okay so my
recommendation is
task
Yourself by holding this
still okay so he's here you're you're a
brand new person and you're going to
feel maybe this rotation do you see or
maybe you're going to feel the shoulders
do you get that okay I don't want you to
go I
relax no you're
training so I want you to prioritize the
positional Integrity if if I start
turning I want you to tense everything
tense tense tense tense to hold it tense
tense to hold it tense tense tense to
hold it okay I want you to do that
instead from
there we will start releasing the
tension so when I was young you would
you help me remember my friend uh what
was that game where you had the the ice
guy in the cubes and you knock cubes out
until he falls a video game no it was
the old Hasbro
game God I'll have to look it up but you
you it's not unlike Jenga but it was
two-dimensional so you put a bunch of
cubes in there and there's a little ice
mountain climber he goes in the middle
and everyone takes a turn knocking out
one of the cubes and then whoever makes
him fall through you lost okay so what I
mean by this is get all the cubes in
place until you start realizing oh this
has nothing to do with what is happening
here do you see and uh neither does my
hand my hand doesn't have anything to do
it's actually past the contention point
you see and uh then you're like keep
going right you're like oh no there's
that shoulder is actually pretty
important don't do that one okay and you
start figuring it
out that it's really a very small thing
that has to maintain Integrity but you
have to start from the big thing and you
experiment as you start
releasing uh more and more of that
muscle tension but if you're just like
here uh and you never
get any structural Integrity we you
you're never going to get there it's
easier to have a mixture of external and
internal structural integrity and then
start taking away those external blocks
you don't need okay so if you watch your
guys's
videos of course do all the other things
I just said before this
happens this knee
goes this knee moves on you really
do you see this knee moves and then
there comes the
shoulder or before go ahead before you
get
displaced your shoulders go back then
you get displaced okay so keep your
shoulders still keep them still keep
them still keep them still keep them
still keep them still and flex whatever
you need to so that this doesn't
happen okay okay and same goes for you
Margaret you you give up too early cuz I
think you're like trying to relax it's
not it's not relax it's a combat thing
right you're going to get hit in a fight
but you're not going to give a damn it's
not going to hit it's not going to
affect you okay that's what we're
showing there so I wouldn't dare get hit
you didn't I didn't want him to push on
my stomach with that one so relax okay
that's not true it's not what we're
looking for all right